more so I feel like when you have like a
work spouse like a lot of the time you
go to that person for the emotional
issues that you're facing in your
relationship so you'll go in and be like
oh she's not having sex with me or oh
he's not treating me this way or
providing in that way so you're going to
them for their you should actually
be going to your husband or wife for
yeah yeah but yeah that's great but it
doesn't start out that way
you know because you
they've been working together for months
if not years so a lot of times it
doesn't start out I mean there might be
some physical attraction but this
usually not how it starts out so hey do
you want to go to lunch you know oh
we've got this uh project this deadline
we might have to work until eight
o'clock and you know a month after month
now they're friends and so of course
friends are going to tell each other
about problems that they have going on
at home